[Musique]
pour l'instant les français peuvent
partir
'l'annonce tout en prudence de jean
baptiste lemoyne le secrétaire d'état au
tourisme parle ainsi des vacances de
février qui commence vendredi pour la
zone a pour l'instant pas de restriction
de circulation
les vacances peuvent avoir lieu après
bien sûr comme vous le savez nos
décisions évoluent tous les tous les
jours tous les quelques jours au fur et
à mesure de l'évolution du virus
[Musique]
je le remercie par anticipation de
m'autoriser à lui poser une question sur
la crise sanitaire
je mesure que c'est un privilège rare
monsieur le premier ministre
depuis que vous et votre majorité
avaient décidé par un coup de force
institutionnel inédit de supprimer la
mission d'information sur la crise
sanitaire
c'est que l'union est en retard très en
retard la faute selon ses détracteurs à
ursula von der leyen qui auraient
commandé trop de vaccins est trop tard
dans toute l'union
à peine 13 millions de doses ont été
injectés j'ai répondu à 23 convocation
entre le sénat et l'assemblée nationale
spécifiquement pour répondre la gestion
de la crise et je le ferai à chaque fois
à chaque fois que cela sera jugée
nécessaire par les parlementaires
c'est tout à fait ma place que de rendre
compte de l'action je crois que les
chiffres sont parlants soit 2,3 pour
cent de la population concernée c'est
beaucoup moins que les autres puissances
mondiales comme israël avec un tiers de
sa population vaccinée le royaume uni ou
encore les états unis plus de 13%
maintenant de la population britannique
très meurtrie par le virus est vacciné
et ils enferment arguments politiques
boris johnson c'est grâce au brésil dit
il que le gouvernement peut aller aussi
vite sans être contraint par la
bureaucratie européenne
aujourd'hui nous sommes en train de
dérouler notre campagne de vaccination
elle se déroule au rythme qui était
prévu alors ça peut paraître trop lent
quand on se compare à d'autres pays qui
avait fait d'autres paris qui sont aussi
des pays qui comme le royaume uni sont
des îles dont peuvent fonctionner
différemment ou les états unis
d'amérique qui eux ont acheté
massivement les tout premiers vaccins
donc vous avez un discours qui est très
bien mais qui est lénifiant je n'ai pas
la réelle impression
on oppose à cette grande image de
responsable des arguments comme ça
gérald à manono dit le voile n'est pas
dans la loi le voile n'est pas dans la
loi on ne parle que de ça c'est la
surenchère à la stigmatisation en
particulier d'une religion et vous allez
voir pendant quinze jours des discours
qui vont déferler dans la laine ne paye
ce n'est pas dans la loi et pourtant on
ne parle que de ça la mère de ce soldat
france je serai par mois modération
vailati soldats français et puis je suis
allé lui dire de retirer son débat et
vous avez parfaitement lorsqu'elle va à
la boulangerie c'est un an et lui parce
que les séparatistes alors que son fils
est mort sur les bananes islamistes
c'est un excellent argument mais a évité
les femmes à quillan 2 oblige le voile
c'est aussi un argument mais évidemment
pension qui connaît qui connaissent des
pressions communautaires
pour
pour nous
[Musique]
c'est une image qui dit bien le
caractère exceptionnel de la crue du lot
sur la rivière une vingtaine de bateaux
emporté par le courant
leur dérive ne s'arrête que 30 km plus
loin entre les piliers du pont de luzech
vous l'avez compris avec un message non
pas une vraie candidature au g aux jo la
ville n'a pas déposé de dossier mais
interpellé sur les conséquences du
changement climatique